okay four people joining this livestream
we are talking about the subject of
iterators which have apparently come up
in a variety of different venues and
this is our attempt to centrally talk
about them so what's the idea right so
there are several levels of structure
here and this goes from the simplest
ideas to the more complicated ones at
the end more generic ones at the end so
the first thing I think it's important
here is that we have multiple
combinatorial constructors like double
subsets groupings etc and for some of
them we allow a way of going directly to
the enth one but not for for example for
tuples or subsets so this is something
that has been requested multiple times
because we know how to do it I guess
with tuples is pretty easy
it's just digits exactly yes so yeah it
may be more or less difficult depending
on the case but it's useful for sure
mainly for all those huge cases in which
constructing all of them like all
permutations beyond 13 elements will be
way too much so I mean interestingly
tuples could have another argument which
is basically it takes back I don't know
exactly how to do it or this may be also
related to the data structures because
the data structure could contain somehow
the symbolic arguments that we provide
to tuples and then they could create
mm-hmm
Fionn elements and in fact that's a
point where tom has been working on the
particular case of permutations as an
example tom here we couldn't get him
today
so that's one one possible idea and then
the next case so I was shown there the
case of permutation groups for which we
do have an algorithm that can generate
the nth settlement for any permutation
group all right so basically what you're
saying is indexing into the case element
so that might be something like tuples
of you know 1 0 20 and then you know
67,000 or something right what's a much
bigger number okay the next case is
finding the next and I and I understand
so it would be something like next
couple from the 1 0 20 and then an
actual tupple whatever it is um
okay
you
I'm where to write where should I save
this to somebody no I don't think you
have any place I'm gonna put it in
functional programming make sense and
people
lifestream sander is pointing out select
tuples and select permutations and the
fashion repository and Carl was pointing
out that Szabolcs had a post about
iterators in the community and right I
think I have some links to Sanders
functions for it
ah Center himself first yes so I think I
think if you open the next section okay
collecting information yeah you see oh
there we go
there is select couples and the flash
exactly so so this is the next step I
mean together with the enumeration of
the elements of a set we want to do
something along the way of eliminating
them which could be a selection case
like this so it's an operation on each
individual object or it could be
something accumulated right so then
another thing that has been suggested in
relation to these several times is the
problem of well I have a such a long
computation that I want to stop it and
then continue so this is a bit like
pointing in numerix you know or it
reminds me also about the state of the
random generator that we have been
discussing with something right I'm sure
there exists some very pure language out
there it allows one to stop its
computation at any point and re and
continue it it seems hard to do so this
is the sort of thing that has to be has
to be prepared for each individual
function we have but and I don't know
whether for example our numerix allow
this so Rob if he added do you know
whether we can we have this sort of
checkpointing capabilities no you don't
know we don't have that we don't we
don't have them I think they're very
hard ok let's look at this general
iterator objects exactly so it's Leonid
here by the way yeah I'm here soon I um
yeah so I let Leonid come in here so
this is about the more general concept
of iterators which you had built for
your Chungking project is that correctly
in it yes but here I tried to be a bit
more abstract because the iterators that
I introduced in the streaming project
part of that complexity was due to
performance and a few other things so
these comments here on your screen they
are more towards generic notion of the
iterator from sort of programming or
software engineering perspective but
okay yeah I understand okay I mean this
is the concept of an iterator that has
an internal state and that's why it's
related to Tom's data structure type
stuff and where you poke it it and it it
it disgorges more tuples or something
yeah but I think this has at least two
different levels at which you can look
at it and one is the sort of interface
one and the other one is implementation
wise because I mean I if you want to I
can give a very short damn about the you
know the interface part of this
discussion like what I mean by that will
probably take like five or ten minutes
away because I just ripped from the
streaming project just the part that is
relevant to this discussion so I can
share the screen show yeah please
another third go for it okay
let me just switch to the right
so so basically our instrument what I
came the idea I came to is that what we
need is more an interface than specific
implementation where you can declare a
certain in iterator interface and this
helped me a lot to just see an example
before we before we told you abstractly
let's just yeah so here is an example
I'm basically constructing an iterator
just from data in memory and it just
contains some you know you know inner
it's symbol and for functions that are
starting the iterator going to the next
element checking whether it's active and
closing the iterator and so here I'm
taking a range of 100 and I'm creating
an iterator from it which is the object
my list iterator I can check whether
it's active or not so currently it's not
active I can also check what is the end
value and this is something that tells
it to stop and then I can I can imitate
it becomes active and then I can start
calling iterator next on it to getting
you know parts of these range hundred or
doing it like that and computing the
total of those chunks and then finally
wait wait wait wait wait wait stop stop
stop stop stop stop what just happened
there so iterator next fundamentally
just pulls a new chunk from the iterator
is that correct yeah okay and and the
iterator is in this case for for
implementational purposes it's chunked
well yes this this particle one returns
to you lists of elements yes um does it
have to Y understandable oh the most
natural next would be a single element
but but for implementation reasons you
want to will return chunks yeah yeah I
just chose this example but again it's
not really important could also return
another objects okay and so then you can
close the iterator and if you try to
okay I get what would happen if you
close it yeah show me some very exciting
well this is a like same thing but here
I'm using file backed yeah but the what
is important is that this still you know
it obeys the same interface so I don't
really care for where this iterator
comes whether it has been implemented
from a file like here or from data I can
just use the same interface where I
basically create an iterator from a file
then I init it I understand
okay so what does the immediate idea
this gives me and it's a really a shame
that Tom isn't here is that in the new
data structures project we could have an
iterator data structure and one thing
that hasn't really been looked at um
with respect to data structure is its
interaction with external things like
files because I could imagine a you know
given that it's maintaining a stateful
interface it can maintain a file pointer
and so on yeah and this idea that you
could have a data structure that is an
iterator or let's say a file iterator
that just allows you to read stuff yeah
this is interesting
yeah but still just I'm sorry in a sense
we already have an iterator concept with
the incredibly low level you know file
reading thing with file pointers don't
we yes but it has a different interface
and I mean the main idea I was trying to
convey here is that the important part
of this thing is the interface that I
define here well I don't really expand
what code defines that interface but
basically are three different
implementations they simply obeyed like
they they satisfy the same interface the
same contract and that's what makes it
flexibility because it it doesn't really
matter from you understand it can be it
can be filed back to commit memory back
to etc but I mean in your concept the
thing you have is the thing that has the
idea of a next element what else does it
have I mean it's kind of a linear object
with the next element concept yeah so
basically you need to define four
functions the initializer the function
that just returns your next element
whatever it is then the function that
checks whether this thing is active and
the function that closes it that's it so
if you define these four functions then
you basically define this interface
implement it early but I think you're
talking about something a little
different then okay so that's
interesting because one could imagine
but now okay the work that you did on
the streaming thing involves being able
to do operations like take a mean or
something of some giant data set with a
billion now yeah sure
how does that relate to this well I can
briefly describe that so basically um
yeah let me just show you so first of
all um yeah I just need to come to the
right slide so um I am using several
types of iterator as in streaming and
they're all based on that kind of idea
one is that I can create this lazy list
object from the iterator over data so
this way abstracts over this way we
abstract over this specific source of
data whether it comes from a gator that
exists or that is materialized at some
later point or whatever but then there
is another
where I'm using it because I'm chunking
data
I actually am using iterators of chunks
so in this case pert for example I'm
getting some you know iterator that is
somewhat different one it's data chunk
iterator so instead of its again the
same interface as you can see me need
next and so on but now instead of
returning you know some simple list of
data that returns objects which are
called data chunks and which have their
own more complex semantics so basically
the way I'm using it for streaming is
that I'm using chunks to make it fast
and so the data or the file whatever is
getting into the system is getting chunk
by chunk so we never use too much memory
on the other hand in the chunk I can use
vectorized operations and make
operations really fast so so I mean I am
using this iterator interface in several
places in streaming but of course
streaming is much more than just this
simple idea but I think one of the
killers so far for streaming has been
what is that source of data because go
ahead I mean it's like where do we find
big chunks of data that are already
digested
oh there are plenty it's just that well
you might not remember but there were
some technical issues we other than that
that we also encountered and which
probably would take one of the things
that I you know one of the problems I
had was okay you know what is that data
is it a CSV file is an HD F file what is
it in the wild you know if we wrote the
data route that's one thing but if it's
coming from somewhere else there are
several sources one can be a huge CSV
files they do exist also in the
databases now that we have this
connectivity databases might contain
lots of data and in some cases
it might be conceivable that people
might want to actually get a lots of
data into Wolfram language well by that
I mean right now the operations and
databases it's the database server that
is doing the you know totaling of a
column or something like this yes yes
going through something I mean but but
let me ask this question if if we wanted
to do something which I keep on being
told as impossible that is to do
arbitrary operations on large amounts of
data and the database is streaming a
possible approach to doing that yes I
think so because basically if you have
if you want to do something more
complicated and databases there are only
two choices either we somehow support
some callbacks from database engine into
or from Colonel which are I think that's
not gonna work but if it's a billion row
you know column that's gonna take
forever to do cool yes yes right or we
do something like what streaming does
and then so basically then the procedure
is that you load lots of data into
Wolfram language in the streaming format
because string format basically saves
them on these conjunct so you don't have
to load all of them in memory and then
also then what you're proposing is the
database writes this out mm-hmm in some
format that is you know it writes out
those billion rows somewhere and then
then we use the the little kind of
streaming head so to speak or maybe
multiple streaming heads if we could do
it in parallel to go and sort of crawl
through that big thing that got written
out how would you write it out if you
were going to do that oh well you mean
syntactically or what will you write it
to I mean what would you write that what
would be the structure that you would
write it oh yeah yeah there is already a
format I have that I implemented when I
was working on streaming which is
basically a collection of MX chunks now
instead of MX chunks there could be for
example double yeah wxf chunks and that
might be even thought so in other words
at what you're saying is if we made an
interface
between databases and wxf we could write
out big chunks of stuff from the
database in wxf there could then be
resident hard-disk somewhere that we
could then need that we can add
interesting and it's actually it's not
that much work already because streaming
does most of it basically that same
iterator thing I was showing to you we
could just create another iterator based
on databases which would be more or less
implementing something similar to this
and then stray and then basically
streaming could consume it and create
those formats on its own so bottom line
if if we wanted to have an arbitrary
function inside entity function would
this allow us to do it yes except I have
to say that because obviously this will
this will only make sense for really
large amounts of data streaming so far
is somewhat limited by what like even
even though I'm trying to use like as
fast things as possible like doctor eyes
operations and so on I think like if
you're asking about arbitrary things
there'll be only as fast as we can make
them to be because they will be using
top level code well hopefully compiled
code yes yes if in fact streaming allows
you to insert compilation inside the
stuff that you're putting in so it's not
very difficult yeah all right great okay
anything else we should see on your
screen and then let's go back oh no I
think I've shown most of what the only
thing I wanted to add to that is that I
think if you want to make things
performant then chunking is essential
okay I understand all right
what's this about more and laziness okay
okay yes the Ender's this connection
with another thing we have discussed
multiple times which is infinite lists
yeah what happened to that chap Louisa's
infinite last thing is that is this a
upgraded version of that or is this a
completely different I think this is a
different approach but that was more
like a symbolic list yes approach which
is something as we have discussed often
times oh by the way streaming does
support infinite lists to some extent
right I'll just mention another another
you know this this iterator thing you
have is quite nicely annoyed and in an
example of something you could do with
it is you could you could put a random
number you know toes I already mentioned
the random number generators so that
that in effect is an infinite list - yes
and in his iterator struct you could put
in a random number general you could
make the in condition that the sum and
the numbers added up to a certain amount
that would quit there so there's lots
you can do it's a very nice idea for a
general structure say that again explain
this again okay so with his iterator
struct you know if we had a way of
entering over things I could set the in
condition to be say say you know the
chunks would be chunks of real numbers
okay that would be generated you could
set the in condition condition to be
that the sum of all the numbers
generated added up to a certain amount
why is that a good idea well that that's
it's just an example but it's it's a way
you could get you could get n ran or
numbers that add up to some number M
great I mean yes okay um sorry III sorry
I apologize my lack of enthusiasm but I
understand the point
I mean yes that's the thing one could do
but so what I mean well I'm guess I'm
just trying to emphasize this there's
this idea is very general right and
doing tuples or this or that right
mutable iterators is that the concept of
some kind of thing where you know like I
don't know that I can demo it is data
structure in the X kernel does anybody
know
anybody have any idea so anybody know
whether tom has put that in
now complete silence do we try to reach
Tom as Tom not available
yeah try to reach him multiple times but
anything oh that's a good sign
well I've no idea this is going to work
but um
you
so it's doing everything
expression wink last maybe that's
encouraging
and you probably know how to look at
figure out the operations that this
thing does
great
um
well let's just
try
I mmm that's encouraging
okay
um
you
I know it is sending me something but
maybe he could send me something more
okay so anyway so I mean if you haven't
seen this that this is some let's see
this is you know this supports certain
operations right I think there's a
better form of it that is
right and so I could imagine that this
is something
you
okay so now if I say yes there
hopefully it'll have length hundred
thousand um not bad ah and I would guess
that I can say right so I mean this is a
mutable data structure right
makes sense and I'm thinking that that
is similar to what you are referring to
as an iterator
yes no yes I think iterators was one of
the structures here
Tom had might I don't I haven't seen it
on a list I haven't seen that on the
list so I wish he was here I wish we'd
arranged this meeting at a time when you
could be here it's kind of silly not to
um whatever if we just do this like I'd
say I mean it there's nothing to discuss
with this
I don't know how you do this I think
maybe there's a thing that says
operations here or something but this
isn't the way it was supposed to be
designed Oh
there we go okay so I don't think I
doubt this is any reasonable I doubt
this is all reasonable yet okay looks
doesn't look very good yet but um what's
my point here my point is from what
you're describing of iterators I don't
see why that shouldn't be supportable in
this framework I think it definitely
definitely can be okay so maybe we
should just implement it there um so
we've got the wrong people here but
maybe this is what we should be doing is
getting you know as one of the
collection of data structures getting a
thing that is an iterator that supports
Leonids operations right I mean it's
basically what it would be and that you
know would be the analog of expression
linked list it will be expression
iterator not that keen on the name
iterator because I think we've used it
for other things and to me it is not an
iterate or is not the repository of the
process of you know getting things but
that would be something which would
support the operations that Lynne has
described you know next etc right and
presumably this iterator would take in
some thing like a file or an existing
expression am I am I correct it could
also presumably take in a much more
advanced world it could take a symbolic
thing like tuples
it could take an unavailing tuples and
then iterate through it I mean that's
kind of a concept here that's the
unifying idea is that you could do these
operations here I mean Lina did not
discuss this operation for example he
discussed this operation yeah but in
fact Stephen I didn't show that but on
Stack Exchange there are a number of
examples where people already did use
streaming even though it hasn't been
documented and extended it was fast
generation of certain things like tuples
and
more complicated combinatorial sequences
and they were showing very good results
for the in terms of speed and memory
usage so well it will explain to me the
top level design well the top level
design is that are basically as soon as
someone creates an iterator of certain
things like sequences of combinatorial
you know combinatorial sequences or
whatever it can be fed to streaming for
efficient processing and for you know
whatever streaming can do that but it
can also be used on its own so as long
as as soon as we have this iterator
thing we could if it becomes a kind of
an interface so the people could
contribute their own implementations
then we'll all that will matter is that
it obeys the same contract in terms of
supporting all those methods and people
could just implement we or other people
what there were solutions they have and
they will be could be used
interchangeably and okay let me look so
just to understand the type of thing
we're talking about here I mean this
could be things we could imagine a
things like file blah blah blah some wxf
file is that what you have in mind that
then if you have that expression
iterator that refers to this thing then
this is you know this mutable data
structure contains a you know pointers
and things like that to different parts
of these
you know different parts of these
structures and presumably the concept
would be that in some future compilation
world I mean this is sort of
combinatorial compilation so to speak
that you can take these common toriel
constructors and turn them into
something that is capable of being
symbolically iterated through is that
right yeah that then turns into you know
in the case of tuples that would turn
into an nth element selector in the
tuples yes so I mean for me the most
important thing for thinking about these
things was to realize that our the
iterator thing that we want is more an
interface than an actual implementation
so that basically I understand but
that's what this I mean this thing here
something like this you know for this
for example
the implementation is non-trivial to
figure out you know if I were to put
instead there you know I don't know what
you know um you know I could say
permutations range of a hundred here
instead yeah right and I mean the
concept is these are sources just like
the file is a source of lots of stuff or
or as rob has been suggesting something
I mean this is very strange but
something which is essentially random
integer um
becomes a you know a source there
although that's I mean that there's a
question of what are the sources of
large amounts of data and one of them is
the internally generated you know
symbolic expression another will be a
file um
the right but I mean I'm confused
okay so in India insider that is like
this this construct that is built-in in
the language where basically you define
a function and you yelled value instead
of return you have some kind of you know
arbitrary code that is just sending
values out the way I was thinking this
could be done in Wolfram language should
be imagined something like creep and so
okay join it so what should I call this
section here this is some symbolic mad
symbolic thing I'll say for now okay so
what's your again imagine something like
repent so but every time you well you
can do something like while true so
something now obviously like if you
evaluate this there we will never go
through right but you can imagine
something where every time you read the
soul you stop the execution right until
someone else is requesting the next
value that would be something very easy
for people I think right I'm not
understanding how that would really work
so all you're saying I have no idea how
this can work but I really like this is
something I would imagine people would
use so Charlie alone our livestream is
talking about monads always who
understands Pascal monads here or do we
have the wrong set of people that was
bad but there's complete silence we may
have the wrong set of people but but
that is I mean who here understands how
Haskell deals with lazy evaluation
because
essentially what you're asking for here
right Ricardo no this is not quite that
Steven I can somewhat explain okay the
problem and why I think it's not very
realistic for Wolfram language right now
is that Python allows you to do that
because python has the notion of
coroutines which are functions where you
can pause the execution of a function
and basically you know instead of
returning discarding the stack the
execution stack you keep the reference
to that stack in the stack frame and
therefore you can resume that execution
at arbitrary moment later this requires
very heavy language support to be
possible I mean there are languages like
go or something which specialize in
having that kind of stuff right yeah I
think go has core routines as well yeah
yes well that'll them go routines yeah
go routines so the other problem with
this approach is that in Wolfram
language every iteration that goes
through is element by element without
chunking is probably going to be slow
unless it is compiled and so this form
will anyway have to be rethought even if
we can somehow manage to do that it
should probably return chunks wait a
minute you're saying multiple different
things here yeah the compiled code
is much more amenable to kuru teen type
execution than the full top-level story
right so it's much more plausible that
we could take a piece of compiled code
and run I mean and the execution engine
for that could use co-routines yes but
these will not be all from language
coroutines this will be lower-level
coroutines
sure but the compiled code I mean if
there was a language construct boy it's
so you know back in the time of SMP back
in 1980 I had this function called fork
in SMP the
ah yeah anyway long long painful story
of early UNIX systems and things um but
any case let me just try to understand
what the language construct would look
like for the thing you are describing
for the co-routine thing that you are
describing I understand that we couldn't
implement it right now but what would it
look like in principle
well basically instead of normal return
in any function you introduce your new
keyword which is called yield as Ricardo
pointed out weights are things we don't
even have co-routines in our spelling
dictionary let's go can somebody report
that the spelling dictionary please yes
um okay go ahead yeah and so there is a
new keyword which you can should be able
to insert virtually anywhere in your
code and that will work almost like
return except you can return several
values within the same function and
every time when you do a return it kind
of gets frozen the code like imagine the
whole execution the code the stack gets
frozen until the next time you call it
and then it returns the next yield so so
we have some function here and it's you
know let's imagine just it's a pure
function it has things in it that's a
yield and yield as in don't yield to
another stream of traffic but yield this
result correct yes and you can have
multiple years like you have say yield
and then another you know some other
names for yield in other languages I
think it's always in JavaScript it's
also yield and go I don't know okay
all right anyway so so what we might
think push-push might be another name
okay a yield just confuses me because it
suggests that I mean yield is also the
punning on the fact that it is yielding
controls something else right but it's
true that's what it does I know I know
that I realize that but the the primary
but so what you're saying is this is
this has the state of this function with
thing ready to be returned yes but then
if you have something after yield like
some some other statements and then
maybe another yield then those will wait
and execute next time when you call this
function and whatever assume it yeah
yeah if you got a print between them you
should not see them if you just
well what item does is provide you a
function that is built-in on so
therefore next and you can call next
several time over our generator and at
the end it will return to you either
Rises an exception something like
iteration stopped our returns to you
like a particular value well okay look
the fact is we have something different
which is in it instead of a stack frame
we have the ability to store what's
going on symbolically so it's not
obvious that there isn't a similar
construct I just don't know what it is
right so imagine that you have this
thing imagine this function is so you're
saying you call this function once and
it returns X you're saying yes and then
it stops exactly after that statement
and waits until you call it next and
when we call it next
it consumes exactly from the same place
so then it will echo and do another
yield and then again stop right means in
our world right it you know the function
could return a you know in the immutable
world that we live in okay the function
could have could return something that
basically says start here could return a
new version of the function that has
says start here
if it wanted to
two returning X it is well if in a
mutable world this would be rewriting
this function to say start here how
would you do it when you have a wild
well when we start I mean probably will
start again well well you're saying
you're saying if there's internal state
in the function but the the whatever
happens that internal state you're
saying inside the while you have a yield
right and you're saying how does it know
what state the while was in when the
yield happened right yeah it will be
hard
on this into kind of symbolic you know
pure function thing that would carry
it's like continuation passing style in
some sense but yes right it is yes but
it's but it's kind of hard
transformation from a turret of code so
I mean well I understand that but but
most of the code that we care about
isn't you know is more like functional
code rather than you know people writing
for loops
I mean clearly it could be done and you
know if you say do it in while it
obviously is doable in a while but the
question is well it's true that like for
example in padam they have this this
concept of coding but every time I use
them it's I use them all the time
because like you you don't use memory
but in the end you always iterate them
through the end I mean it never happened
to me that I was using next manually or
that I need to do you know so that those
kind of functionalities needs to be
there but Leonard the end people will
always iterate it you know they will
join iterate or they will to a select
over them you can map over them okay
just registration but then at the end
you you always do it in one shot in
order to save memory you never you know
manually go next and really care about
you know doing explain to me why bottom
line is for what you actually do well
the bottom line is that you you okay for
example you can connect to a database
and when you iterate a query invited you
will return an iterator and stree you
can iterate this guy want one by one and
you don't get back 10,000 result and and
then you can do operation over those
10,000 results by just you know
iterating one by one and I understand so
it's the same concept again that you
have in form of this expression iterator
and what you've got there you know
another type of thing that you have is
some kind of database query here
for example yeah just to understand um
ah you know just to understand the
concept again we have a source so I
don't know whether this is relevant here
but but the you know the fundamental
thing we have a source of large amounts
of data and the issue is how do we you
know how do we process that data without
you know having it all in memory or you
know or even necessarily generating it
all right that's that that's the general
problem we're trying to solve correct
yeah and you know some version of this
is the data exists somewhere like it's
in a file the data doesn't exist it's
symbolically represented by a huge
tuples or something or it's something
like random integer or it's or it's
potentially a generator here that is
some kind of what can we do you know
it's it's a it's a recursion relation of
some kind you know it's some you know
some kind of recursive thing that just
is computed from things before it we're
we're kind of toast in terms of where we
can only go forwards right in the case
of tuples we can imagine some math that
lets us dive into the middle of it right
in the case of you know if that
recursion is Fibonacci then we know how
to dive into the middle of it am I
making sense but there
Persians we can imagine where they're
you know this is the world of
computational irreducibility basically
but there's no way to dive into the
middle of it
am I making sense so for example let's
let's take this example actually a
really good example let's take the
center column of rule 30 and let's say
you know we've got this and we've got
some you know we got rule 30 and we've
got some let's say yeah there we go
so that would be um let's say a hundred
steps there okay there they are now
let's say I want steps you know
let's say let's say I make this B 10 to
the 10 to the 8 or something and then I
hold that and I now say okay give me
steps number such-and-such through
such-and-such
am i making sense so I just put these
put up these prize problems for whether
whether that's possible so to speak
I'm a making sense so in other words
there are functions you can define here
we're jumping ahead is sort of
guaranteed to be impossible
there are other things like a file where
yes you could jump ahead or random
integer you probably can't jump ahead if
it's a supposedly cryptographically
secure one you shouldn't be able to jump
ahead okay so we got things where you
can jump ahead you've got things where
you can't jump ahead we've got things
where you can chunk read them um and
um
am I going the right directional people
think I'm off off-track here I think
this is the right direction well yeah I
would suspect also to be able to put
these things in the second argument of
stable and do right I see what you're
saying so in other words so uses of
iterator data structures so you're
saying I mean you're saying I could say
table blah blah blah
you know iterator
or you're saying and that these are this
is really all you're saying it's a part
iterator bla bla bla that's the you know
that's select the earth element of the
thing
or you're saying it's select across the
iterator with a criterion what else
would you like to be able to do I was
thinking of table xxx I come a traitor
yeah exactly that's what I have in mind
yes
sorry I was saying mappings can
obviously
yeah but that's not so useful because
well I mean literally look these are
okay look these are whole gulp
functions right and these are sort of
small bite functions which are different
right because that's that's really going
to be you know something like map well
scan is is a sort of a mixture right
because it's so let me interfere for
just a second
I think iterator should have absolutely
minimal interface because something like
streaming was created exactly for more
sophisticated operations or an iterator
is effectively like sparked like map
like all these things and iterators
themselves should be doing the minimum
number of things they can like more or
less that interface I was showing yeah I
understand that but I'm trying to
understand great so this thing here is
an iterator right one of your iterators
okay so then scan just you know eats in
little pieces of the iterator going in
you know in chunks or whatever else and
doing its job but what why is that
different from what I'm showing here let
me explain either way there is our I
think they be they they are stateful and
exhaustible and so you do this scan once
and then someone tries to do it next
time
and it array there is already that's a
different thing right but I mean so
that's this case up here right where I
mean that's the file pointer idea
effectively if an iterator was a in a
file referred to a file it's moving the
file pointer yeah but in general it has
to be I mean no it doesn't no it doesn't
I mean in this case here it doesn't
that's a different thing you you you
know that's a case that has the same
basic semantics but it works differently
no you're not going to exhaust the
tuples so to speak yes but I think we
should distinguish between iterators
that are still sort of mutable and for
tuples it's more like lazy list of
tuples which you can access at any point
this is not exactly the same well I
don't think this is correct I mean I
think that look take the case of a file
right where it is in some sense
exhausted because the file pointer just
walked down to the end of the file but
you could also move the file pointer
back in the file probably unless the
file is some kind of stream where you
can't do that
yes but given that example with the file
pointer if you take like for example
table of something with that file
pointer and you run it once then you can
probably reset the pointer but from just
looking at this you wouldn't know that
you have to and you if you repeat it
twice the second time it will break
unaware I'm aware I think that's kind of
cruddy design actually I mean I think
that look you're defining you're saying
there is a mutable thing that you can
sort of progressively consume and then
you've got to the end of it I get it
yeah that's a sensible thing right but I
don't think you should say that's
everything that we have to talk about
yes okay I don't think that's the most
important aspect of these things but my
point is that the other things that
you're mentioning where you can reset
things go back have random access
they are already somewhat different data
structures not iterators it's maybe it's
a certain terminology you know
mismatched I think this is a matter of
remembering history so whether we have
an iterator that remembers what
generated and then it represents a whole
list all the time independently of what
it is in generation or the ones that do
not remember what they generated so each
time you call them they represent the
rest of the list right well that's
mutable versus immutable but I would say
that that more consistent with our
language would be to have table and scan
when they work on an iterator they
actually work on a copy of the iterator
so they basically but we already
localized the RM table why couldn't we
localize the iterator as well yeah
and that's what streaming actually is
doing that's why I try to distinguish
these things so that these functional
operators should work on things which
are not really exhaustible which are may
be based on exhaustible things but as
you say work on copies all the time
have a bunch of interesting comments on
our live stream here all sorts of things
let's see
things about threading chunks chunks
sizing yes Sandra is asking a table with
two poses optimized I'm afraid the
answer is now um
you know sander is mentioning something
he had mentioned to me previously which
I thought was an interesting idea and
which will probably come up in different
meeting because I know I sent it in
about having tables with them with
associations which I I like this idea
and I'm believing being the very next
meeting that we have this this idea I
know think it's relevant specifically to
this Jalil is talking about monads and
unfortunately we don't we have a bunch
of Haskell enthusiasts and experts in
the company but none of them are in this
meeting
um the UM howling processing sinc async
state or other type of data Ethan is
talking about paging through a PI spark
data frame by the bottleneck is
processing time per core and might be
asynchronous um yeah let's see
synchronous and asynchronous well yeah
that that's the synchronous asynchronous
story is again related to this you know
gulps bytes um question of whether you
copy question whether things are
immutable question of whether you're um
yeah um
right closing a socket Stream opera
so put a reader that maps over data as
it comes in operates on the right hand
side indeed yes well okay so just just
to to try and um um I mean okay so
clearly we can have an expression
iterator structure in Tom's data
structure project and that should be
able to happen quickly and the question
is what can it operate on so to speak
what is it being fed as a as its
authority so to speak as its source of
iteration content what do we think are
the top things for it to be being fed
right because you know we could feed it
a generator function so Leonid you have
defined so let's let's look at um you
know III demesne what is returning I
mean what what does select of either a
tour or a list I'm sorry what are you
saying what is select of iterator
returning is is returning another
iterator I guess right so you need to I
think it has to be okay if you want that
to work but that's a much more advanced
thing I mean in other words okay so look
look there there's a sort of symbolic
operations okay so this is a whole
different story
imagine you have an iterator and you say
select on the iterator iterators
structure let's say um select on the
iterator structure with you know hash
greater than zero and you say that is
going to return another iterator
structure that has in it the extra
condition that oh don't return anything
that's less than zero in fact I was
asinine difficult to implement I have
already implemented that in streaming
for iterators it's really well not hard
okay so what you're saying is what this
is doing is it pushes you know this
effectively pushes the Select
inside the next function of the iterator
yes okay fine I don't
else you can push inside I mean there's
presumably a calculus of what you can
push inside you can do a limit for
example by limiting of how many other
elements you want to return or you can
do join or you take to my raters who are
kind of join ah just the usual join just
like as if you would have lists
okay lazy so you
Raiders you get another one which will
first exhaust the first and then exhaust
the second I understand yeah and I have
sent you an email with a with an idea
that was couple of years old and if it's
relevant there is a notebook you okay
but just to repeat a little bit about I
remember this I remember this Ricardo
yes okay thank you for bringing this up
it's a pity this wasn't on it was this
known to Jose in and the song I I forgot
to send it before you got this meaning
yes I never discussed it at some point
okay okay yeah so let's take a look at
what you've done here so in the idea
here was very simple basically it's it's
either a door it's old old flat and it's
very nice because you have just joined
us to expression together although I
just want to take this in the right
place um let's see
you
you
yes okay let's
- yeah okay yes I mean there was an
implementation I was not really working
perfectly but it's I mean if you're
honest should still work so yeah it is a
result door and flat and so you can just
so if you do normal it's it's doing the
evaluation okay what two expressions so
what does this mean
hold on what does this mean this means
yeah this is yes this is right
yes it just runs okay so how does this
relate to what we what we're seeing over
here with these days that's very simple
very immutable version of I mean that is
an immutable one because every time you
you iterate it it will start from the
beginning yours this implementation does
yes yes right okay but so what you're
doing here is you are having a
essentially this is a symbolic so in
some sense yes so and there are a couple
of
operations that are implemented because
I think like the basics operation that
you need in order to implement
everything else is just select map and a
reducer and and with those three
operation that are done lazy I think you
can okay so wait a minute so this is
this is symbolic creation but this is
essentially procedural creation of a
symbolic iterator
I climb yeah and the problem is that as
Lyra was saying like this is impossible
to stop but if hold on it really works
from the design that we want to do
because if the design constraint is we
don't want individuals to be mutable
then this one I think fits well
algorithms okay so hold on so this is so
essentially what this is if I might
understand it is this is a sort of push
into in a sense if I have an iterator
this is which is some symbolic
expression if I say push into this thing
I get back in iterator correct
this is like an append to you might yeah
and then all that will join that will
join the iterator with just a new a
derivatives just continue push off yeah
hmm right so okay so then this is and so
normal of that as you say is just
unravels it is a list
right but the whole point is what you
could do here is you could say push into
you know iterator and then some kind of
thing maybe although I don't really know
how it splices you know ahold of a giant
tuples
yeah that we return that will not mutate
the previous one in whether they're a
new one I understand I understand it yes
it's understand it's taking this
well you you could make it right the
question of whether it's mutable now is
a different question but what this is
doing is it is appending to the symbolic
structure this thing that is hold of
tuples and then it is allowing you it
has certain operations for eating
through this thing but again we're back
to the same question of there are things
like a file that we you know and it's
again back to Leonids point that there
are certain primitives like get the next
element um the UM the let's see you know
okay we have a bunch of interesting
comments on our live stream here um
like is Jaleel is saying like as a map
softly trouble
okay so he's saying um given that app
hash plus
miserable returns
yeah an iterable thing and whatever you
call it an iterator yes I agree that
that that is a symbolic transformation
on I mean that's what we're talking
about here a symbolic transformation
honor I mean that up there would be a
symbolic transformation on an iterator
that returns an iterator there that is
that has then figured out how to add one
to every element even though it never
looked at every element that's the point
I mean that's the key key idea here is
you know turns into an iterator and this
happens you know even though it doesn't
look at each element actually that's
precisely what lazy least construct from
streaming is behaving like okay yes it
does exactly this
except I also introduced chunking in
there but that's a detail
yeah yeah I mean I completely agree that
that that the idea of a of a of each
function having to have its own special
thing is hopeless
the difficulty with some of these things
the question is can you make it so that
an arbitrary function I mean you could
presumably make in our world up values
um then um you know to insert this in is
not difficult and some of these things
will be compiled able right so in other
words if the operator if the operation
is f of iterator if f is compiled able
then that's absolutely something that
can be efficiently done and if F isn't
compiled able well sorry it'll have to
run not compile but that's okay it'll
still work yeah that's exactly how also
how streaming oryx whenever I see there
listable or vectorized operations I
apply it right but so the point is that
there are certain operations that are
very special in iterators like the kaif
part would be something that we would
you know that there's some operations
that would be sort of deeply built-in
again
there are operations like the okay wait
a minute so first point is listable
operations
actually that's not even really the
point I mean that there's a list of
operations are rather straightforward
it's very easy to understand what they
would do right
they're just applying if if F is
listable then F of an iterator is just
essentially mapping F over the elements
of the aerator right
whereas something like this would have
to have special code effectively to
handle what you do with these iterators
particularly when you have more than one
iterator in an operation am I making
sense I mean and I'm sure you know more
complicated cases are things like you
know if I did map thread across to Italy
iterators that would get complicated
right I mean that's it's that could be
made to work but that's not it's not
obvious you have to have a
correspondence between the iterators and
so on but many operations would would
then just work but now that the question
again is in one of these iterators okay
so how do you get things into an
iterator how do you and and so Ricardo
has the suggestion of the you know
procedurally pushing things
progressively pushing things into an
iterator that's one suggestion for how
to get things in right another
suggestion is it comes from a file
another suggestion is it comes from a
symbolic structure or it comes from a
function
um yeah I think like if you use the
approach that you know you give me the
index and I'll give you and and with a
function I produce the next one this is
an iterator that you know you can ask
like any
any point of this iterator and you know
and you don't meet to construct
everything gets right unless is
something like Fibonacci n where when
you basically need to know that the
previous one
well Fibonacci is not a bad case because
Fibonacci is mathematically solvable the
bad case is rule 30 where we believe it
isn't mathematically solvable yeah but
it and that is the case of an iterator
where basically you know get all the
features the immutable one at least we
start implementing confidence basically
it's an expression and needs to evaluate
between yet so you cannot really stop it
the problem like for example you cannot
do a variation like transpose in this
case yet like Twitter a dots and you
need to transpose them you can why am I
gonna do that
it seems that seems like that's very
much the same as the joint operation I
mean the these are or map thread you
know transpose of two iterators is just
going to be I mean this this obviously
it's not obvious that they're not ragged
and things like this I mean for example
if those iterators both have next
generators in them what is your
guarantee that they actually line up and
so that the usual transpose operation
would would actually be meaningful you
go what I'm saying yeah but you can
define I mean as long as you somehow can
check that the length is the same you
can proceed well right if you have a
length operation that's defined which
you may or may not have just mentioning
the concept of maps and actions and yes
that you can define something
symbolically in our world it's
symbolically and other in other
languages it wouldn't be symbolic and
that then then something causes it to
actually unravel and stop being lazy and
actually do something but still one
sorry for interruption but I have a
suggestion in case if we continue these
meetings about iterators because I have
implemented already a bunch of these
things in streaming I could be Oh give a
short demo for like half hour maybe less
explaining how these things already work
within streaming and trying to keep away
from too technical details just you know
main that would be useful but I I feel
like I mean for me I'm just trying to
understand the thing which really
stopped us on the streaming project
which was where does the data come from
that you were streaming in right I
understood from before from several
years ago you know how effectively you
can work with chunks once you have a
data source that you can stream in yeah
it's all good okay the problem is where
is the data source and to me you know
we've we've now defined here a few
places which all have different
characteristics of what those data
sources might be and to me it's again I
would like to see and it's a really a
pity that Tom hasn't been here but but I
would like to see Tom put into his data
structures collection an expression
iterator that you know I'm still trying
to understand it because again there are
these different sources let's just make
a small list here sorry I'm going to of
you know sources of material sources of
content for an iterator okay and let me
just put this somewhere so I remind
myself what that list is okay so one
source of content is essentially
symbolically defined collections okay
and an example of that is hold of tuples
okay
another example another thing is
sequentially computed functions an
example of that is our friendly cellular
automaton
and these cannot be or or a or a random
number generator right so these cannot
be shortcut it right there's no way to
get the nth for one of these there's an
intermediate case between these which is
symbolically defined quote solvable
our cases an example of that would be
Fibonacci okay well we
with our solve and get the end of term
okay so another source here is yeah okay
in this one also we've got hold of
permutations of range of 100 um okay so
another source is data from a file okay
another source is data from a streaming
data source eg an IOT device or
something where where the future is not
knowable ie where the past might be
stored future is unknowable until it's
ready to come in um
the okay let's see another case is data
from a database right which is sort of
you know which is probably more in a
single chunk than the stuff from the
file even okay so another case is
symbolically inserted material so that's
the case where we're doing push two of
the iterator blah blah blah
I proceed procedurally some we could
even say procedurally inserted material
okay what are we missing
ethan is saying on the Nostromo source
of content anything that is enumerable
yes but we need to break it down a bit
more than that
yes I mean so okay so what kind of thing
are we missing here because I think we
need to understand that some of these
have the property that you can get the
nth term and some do not
yeah so I was saying like the the case
where you have like while true and you
do things and unless you don't proceed
only in certain materially no I think
that's a finite this this in this case
I'm talking about finite procedurally
inserted material ok so then then
there's then there would be the case of
which I don't really understand very
well of infinite procedurally inserted
material doesn't need to be infinite but
I mean let's see that I'm just
implementing data from a file by myself
I just do you know open fire and then I
read the line and then I push the line
one by one without blowing up the memory
that is fine no no no I I don't
understand that then you've you've got
okay that that is essentially defining a
raw next operation right yeah unless I
mean right so that isn't that that's
that's you know that's a define your own
stop eration right which is in a sense
lower level than any of these many of
these could be folded in to define your
own next operation but by the way define
your own next operation isn't relevant
for this case here as such doesn't need
to be
this is non-trivial to go from that
symbolic expression to a next operation
can be done but it's non-trivial
yeah but that's exactly the whole point
what that in order to form the iterator
you need to formulate what the next
operator operation is no I'm keep on
saying yes that's your version of what
an iterator is this meeting started by
discussing things that are like this
okay and that's where we get confused
okay okay
because this in our symbolic language is
probably not far away from what you're
talking about it just doesn't happen to
be exactly the same thing
yeah I guess if you can move arbitrarily
to arbitrary point then you don't need
necks obviously no but you can define a
next but the next isn't the natural
thing necessarily um
well I guess my point is that that
contracts construct that I was showing
with those methods basically unifies all
these cases now it doesn't know I think
yes well it doesn't it doesn't cover
these kinds of cases what you were
showing is the you know you're showing
look look okay so primitive operations
you were showing assume that the
primitive operations are you know next
what else did you have you have well
basically you're open close yeah because
it's mutable and something like check
next or check said well it's check next
well is there a next is there a next yes
and next
itself right okay fine you know we
started this meeting up here talking
about this that's a different story
well it can be it turns out for this
particular problem there is a solution
to convert it back to that what do you
mean I mean that you can define
basically you can find a way to get
topples from say thousands to thousands
and tens and therefore you can obviously
also define next as well if you have
that that's more than next that's even
stronger condition so you can move
the doubles without even knowing the
history so that's silly let's come back
let's come back to what we actually
wanted to do here so we've got
operations that we want to perform on
these things right here okay so we've
got things like parked get the cake part
so you know let's say I want the
thousandth part and all I've got is a
next operation clearly I just run next a
thousand times and I get the thousandth
part yes all right now if on the other
hand it is a form where once I have the
thousandth part you know any part that I
have in the past is forgotten then I'm
kind of toast if I want to get the 500th
part next right not necessarily well yes
you are unless you remembered what you
have if what was coming was some data
from an out IOT device and it's gone and
you didn't store it and you say let me
you know get in data let me take the
measurement a thousand times to get the
thousandth measurement but I didn't
remember what I already got then you
clearly can never go backwards now maybe
that's not what we're talking about here
but but and you know if we're looking at
some of these other operations yes but
that's exactly my point
that in for example when I I mean I was
solving all these problems trying to
solve when I was designing streaming and
that's why I mean I try to separate the
iterators themselves which are sort of
sequential one by one and more
complicated data structures like what I
have a laser list which allows you to
not go back because it has certain
caching for example to remember is how
many elements were in each chunk so it
knows where to push iterator so if
iterator allows you to move without
remembering history it will remember
where to move it next time and so
effectively it will solve this problem
so no problem but the problem that is
but you are saving you are saving all of
them right because
in the first place I'm saving that yes
yes I there is a cash but I am also
saving cash obviously is limited but I'm
also saving things like if I chunk date
I'm saving the length lengths of chunks
so if I want to just get certain
specific you know random access to data
I don't have to go through all of the
chunks I getting all right so let me
understand so for example in the
framework that you had would map thread
have worked yes it does already I have
implemented that
well how many functions have you
implemented across your chunks um I can
tell you specifically which just give me
a second I'll check but basically for
really lazy because there is a eager API
and there is a lazy API so basically
what I have is flat and joined map map
indexed part replace part reverse select
to in spose and stobbles
but there isn't generic strategy there
is a generic framework of how to add
more in principle so like random choice
would be an example well that one was
actually the last one I was implementing
and yes there is a branching stream were
implemented that but that was a hard
problem yeah and it's like the database
randomness problem right well you know
somewhat similar how to select it until
you can see everything yeah I mean I
managed to get some solution which was
reasonably efficient by chat by some
clever chunking scheme but it wasn't
trivial problem sampling assumptions
about the data yes I haven't seen the
whole data you can't know that you're
getting a random element yes
so ID I need make certain sampling
assumptions indeed but so let me just
understand it what you believe you have
if we look at these sources of of
content okay you know
okay you don't have this type of content
particularly well I kind of do because I
have implemented two tuples so yeah I do
was specifically for this
Topol sir yeah but that is true that in
any case you will need to do an
implementation again for all those
functions absolutely so the thing I was
showing this abstract iterator interface
was just the kind of umbrella that
allows you to implement specific things
maybe Stephen
it won't take really long if you just
give me a screen I could show you just a
couple more things so for it yes
all right so ah there is the you see the
raw basically okay this is this lazy
tapas thing but here someone wanted to
get efficient way to implement lazy weak
compositions so so what this guy did he
like he tried several things but then
finally this is what it took him to
implement it and combine it with the
streaming he was using streaming so he
basically just implemented the iterator
it's the same thing as I was showing
mm-hmm but just was his uh you know uh
his own implementation and then he
plugged it in and after he plugged it in
he could basically get all these things
and you could do you know scan or other
operations on them just as if they would
be built-in and it really doesn't take
him long to it's just this much code to
add this to streaming your streaming
interface works yes yes yes even though
it wasn't documented but it is in the
builds so he was able to actually do
this and then what he did is it in wait
a minute is it in all built yes it is in
the builds right now it's somewhat
broken though but there is a patch that
one can apply I mean I wasn't really
looking into making it fully working
because it was sort of shelved project
but people are still using it and so
what he did what next he did the library
linked implementation of chunks and then
he plugged those chunks into streaming
and let me show you he shows that if you
don't use streaming use something else
there are some memory charts how much
memory
takes but if you use streaming then he
was showing that memory usage goes to
plateau so it basically you can see with
the streaming you are you can you can do
this chunking without the increase of
memory and so and the same guy did the
similar thing with the alternatives to
subsets and he was also using streaming
and again the same thing so my point is
it's pretty extensible I'll stop sharing
now well that's interesting it's pretty
extensible already so it has been
already built for this kind of purposes
that's why I was thinking that maybe if
I give a short demo next time it might
be useful I always find I find it very
hard to understand for some reason maybe
somebody else here can help me well I
can try make it so that it we are not
going to drown in details just give you
a few examples based on this list that
you have a source yeah that would be
useful that would be very useful and if
what you could do is to take these kinds
of sources of content yeah I can and and
these kinds of operations yes I can then
that will be very helpful yeah I can I
can specifically make a demo based
centered around these things and um oh
boy this is the meeting we're supposed
to do next which we're super late for um
let's see sorry I'm just looking at
we have many of the people who are
relevant to that meeting already here
right Hosea is that this is your meeting
right yes so they're two first points we
need to do the others are not so
important well for for folks I did not
maybe we should just segue and and
change the group of people who are in
this meeting and just go and try and
handle these these points rather than
starting a separate meeting for this um
and ask the couple of people who were
going to join this meeting to join us
here cuz they already have almost
everybody ok so then then conclusion on
iterators leonid is going to try and
make us a demo based on his technology
and you you understand I think I
understand what Ricardo has done here
and you understand that also right that
there's an there's a procedural
operation that pushes things into
iterators yes
a different idea there which yeah I'll
need to look again at it with regardless
show that the color you are impossible
to hear
sorry yeah we'll send a nematode to
everyone with and I I didn't really
understand how that I mean I'd like to
see how things worked with tuples with
your iterator construct all right well
great maybe I'll finally understand
every mean again the the place where we
ran into trouble before as far as I was
concerned and maybe my misunderstanding
was the sources of content problem but
if if I think we've now clarified that I
look forward to seeing this sounds good
um and but please communicate with Tom
and see if there's something easy that
he can do in the data structures project
um with this might make sense Leonard
yeah sure so can you send this notebook
dude that you just agree that can you
send this out some Carl yes hopefully
who is becoming you Devon yeah I can
email it out please
um and we you also appearing the I'll be
meeting or somebody else doing that at
native okay that's what I thought so um
okay all right let's switch people and
nice two minute we can get some if we
can get the additional people for Aldi
in this meeting then we will just segue
to those topics so thanks to folks who
are here for the iterator thing we're
gonna start talking about other stuff
now thanks bye bye bye umm okay we'll
segue into this yes I think we need
Heidi for this first discussion okay and
yes so we have she has some proposals
for the new type setting off a lighter
type setting of data objects this is the
new one yep and something exactly
so I particularly like so that's a
current one yeah so this middle one
looks what's the difference the
generality is bolder in the lower
example
yeah I understand I'm both for input and
output or we're gonna differentiate and
put an output I think for input it's
more like this and for output it's more
like this isn't it exactly yeah
I mean unfortunately by sticking day in
there I mean you know Saturday sets of
June you you kinda you don't say it's a
day I mean yeah for days it's very
obvious but I mean year for example we
need it we cannot just put a number
right right what if we had no weeks or
something maybe important did heidi join
us here I'm trying to get her right now
she hasn't joined yet okay well the
horrifying story of curry yes indeed and
then Fujio things that they haven't
shown you yet so I wanted to so this is
this is the generalization of the new
notation for polygons with holes
generalize to the Geo world so now it
supports entities and your positions etc
so the idea is that polygons now can
take a rule with the outer ring on the
left-hand side and the inner rings what
happens if there's an island with an
alarm with an island so to speak the
lake with an island within a lake with
on an island right thing that has to be
a different so so the holes this is a
polygon that represents is essentially
an annulus and you can't have another
polygon sitting inside the hole then
it's a separate polygon that's what
you're saying exactly yes
well I have in discussing with Charles
the possibility of having many outer
rings on the left hand side and then
polygon realizes in real time which is
inside which but at the moment that that
kind of work we need to have separate oh
well this is cool so okay looks looks
fine to me I mean it just has to be
documented yeah
and presumably we have geo entities
famously you know the San Marino and
Lesotho problems so to speak
we have geo entities that have holes and
have we now recoded the polygons that
they evolved on them
not yet they are still return as field
cars which is what we were using before
this notation which was introduced in 12
and yeah eventually we will change but
we need to make sure that we return two
different versions of the portion
language the proper things because this
this is from clear I understand and do
we have that capability from the
geoserver yes we do and question how
many of the administrative divisions of
the world I don't really remember how
many there are but but there are lots
and we're continually updating them how
many have holes in them do we know is it
Lots or is it just a few it's not many
and some domains actually have not been
updated to support falls so country that
support holes and for example the main
polygons of the world does need holes
for the Caspian Sea and some other
places so so this is particularly part
of a country for a country type yeah but
I mean what about I mean I think there
are even cities that have you know holes
in them so to speak yes but what I mean
is that we don't support holes in those
yet with countries so but but yes why
don't we what what's the difference in
the support it's a historical thing
initially there were no holes anywhere
and then we started adding them in
countries via thinkers now I understand
that instead but what what cares about
whether there's a hole well other than
the final geo renderer nothing nothing
it's a matter of creation okay fine yeah
and question I mean geo area for example
correctly accounts for polygons with
holes I assume yes yes also we still
cops right okay and then this is
something you found randomly last week
which is that the region's framework is
now able to understand polygons
where do you put back tacular yes so
cool yep look at that right or do you
have the wall there that's really cool
and so yeah so it's both both in terms
of graphics and then in terms of
computation so for example area now know
what to do with the polynomial position
mm-hmm
we'll take everything in meters and then
in the projective spaces will happen the
same thing that we always do it's in the
previous section which is that it uses
that the units of that projected space
whether it is degrees or a sorcerer what
are you saying yes so if you go to the
previous section subsection yes so here
for example there is a little bit
further down there is this example
comparing gear area yes so there you see
how we say we take that your regret
reservation exactly so so every axle I
understand so the geogrid position is
unitless and it's a pure area I mean
it's implicitly using meters exactly
it's boy even in the even in the does
the USGS use meters everybody uses
meters right it's not there's no
imperial units anywhere in that world in
geo grids nobody is using you know miles
in a in some kind of geogrid is that
correct it's me - I mean there are
projections in which okay so then the
geogrid position area could end up being
in square inches or something exactly
it's whatever the the projection there
this is this isn't in given in this
reference model so the reference model
is the one determining what what are the
units being used and how do you find out
the units from that reference model
because
is an NGO production data it is in India
today that the reference models are
geodesy data objects so if you do
geodesy data and then for example say
ellipse ellipsoid parameters or semi
actions ellipsoid parameters so they are
to get it's in meters and and that
number is a form of giving eccentricity
eccentricity
it's called flattening inverse flooding
I see it means the relative video for
the earth is one three hundredth away
from being a sphere yes so that means
the polar axis is 1 over the number
shorter than they should have known that
I don't know
ok all right ok but anyway this is
giving the unit's there yeah all right
well this looks great is there anything
to figure out here no it's just and now
one can compute a region centroid is
probably gonna be a real position
etcetera
wonderful it's also that now we will
find many many more places polygon of
geo grid position also meaning it hasn't
projected to a map with an explicit
projection sorry sorry so we'll find
what polygon of Geo grid position in the
past we always found polygon of geo
position yes but that's an object that
doesn't know a projection so now we
support also polygons of Geo grid
position which contains a projection I
say yeah great and did Heidi come she is
here yes ok all right so the basic thing
is to get rid of the cutesy skeuomorphic
calendar ii thing and the only issue
here really to my mind I mean do we have
code that some prevents public will be
tried on a bunch of cases you know I
don't know what there's gonna look like
if you say year : 2015 or something um
and what happens when it's like century
beginning
you know how does that work the weird
things with the beginning 1900 and so on
versus beginning 1901 yeah I don't I'm
not familiar with those examples so I
have to Jose what what what happens in
that case it it's an integral rarity are
labeled that they will all be written
there blacks you know what will it say I
mean yes so we can do an example like
covering day so let's do let's do date
object look at the data object here yes
so how do we get a list of priorities
it's Sam
why don't I scrape it okay okay so now
let's go ahead and say date object of
now your current date of the screen
righties
I see that's what we're doing for these
probably the least satisfactory this is
the day one I feel like it still needs
something at the yeah so far we only
removed the granularity from instant and
and that's the difference we are making
between we mean the second or we mean
the instant okay so that's what you're
proposing for this right exactly so that
means the current instant as opposed to
that second I mean it's kind of obvious
that this is a day isn't it yes so we
could have the convention that for days
we do remove the Aryan rarity I think of
months as well I think for months we
could do it too they could do it for
instance days and months everything else
we can't do it for right that's what I
would propose and then in terms of the
format here I don't know why this went
quite so dark here
I think this lightness Heidi and I mean
I don't even know why she has a proposal
our baths which is light them so it's
just a different purpose I see okay and
the blueness what do we think the
blueness means and how does it relate to
other blue things we have well it's kind
of random isn't it I mean yeah but
blueness tends to mean a link of some
kind
yeah I was just taking it from what was
already there I thought color would be a
discussion you would want to bring up
but I don't know what I mean what other
things do we have that are why did we
put this incredibly heavy weight thing
in in the first place does anybody
remember you know that's been around
longer than a lot of these new icons
that we've been adding so I think it was
one of the first and now I think you
would call it a crutch yeah but so how
does this relate to other things so for
example the new entity stuff who I don't
know who's been designing that who's
that's not you is it Heidi it's been
it's um I did put it at the top of my
mark the entities are just a straight
pod with no design you'd mention that no
that's a different thing now that you
mention entity yesterday Brett mentioned
the possibility of having granularity in
the same way that we have the domain
like after and with capitals
just an idea yeah I don't think it's
gonna work well these are very long
words and I like weak beginning you know
we're not gonna have that as a postfix
I said weak began such-and-such well I
was more concerned with his external
identifier and so on what are you
showing us here Oh Jeremy put this
notebook together when he heard about
this meeting
well maybe Jeremy should join us me see
if he's back from lunch he is gonna join
us then please
[Music]
um that's very small font there um
astronomy joining us
soils in links yeah that's a small font
I mean that that matches the x-height of
these other things well no it doesn't
actually I think we need Jeremy for this
okay the big enchilada
whatever this meeting is the courage
discussion
yes I yeah your proposal there could be
a solution operate your slide reverse
applied yes I I do think we need the
word operator so that's why I was
suggesting there carry operator just to
make it closer because this is still
very very close to carry itself with
what we all agree on is that a word
operator by itself along standard yes so
it needs something else so it could be a
PI I think that if I saw this in code
operator applied F it would not be
absolutely incomprehensible and reverse
supplied
what do you think that would mean I mean
would that mean something reasonable
didn't their origin of the reversed was
order we wanted to use F goes to
reversed order to mean in inserting
functions that we should use no no no I
know that but I mean so so what do you
say you're saying if I say sort by or
sort rather sort by sort by a list as
our own our reversed apply order so how
does that look
first order looked very nice to the
order
so yoga's like traversed
I mean the reverse is of the arguments
yes I mean it's nice for that case but
what about other uses of reversed other
nice users it uses our products like you
are using the reversed
what permutation product for some people
who want left to right what do you mean
well how would it help you there I mean
it just it's it's a I mean if you have I
mean if I said reversed of integrate mmm
know that that's let's use and what is
another non commutative product or what
about this wasn't it why why wouldn't
this work see what's a little weird is
the reverse does a headdress so to speak
but it is affecting
I have to say that I think reverse
applied might be easier to understand
here oops
what about arc arc of reversed argh argh
no I mean we don't argost like for a
complex number you know well you're
saying
that's hopeless I think that seems too
weird okay so if we said operator
applied of F it would say represents the
function f to be applied in an operator
form that's pretty reasonable reverse
supplied represents the function f see I
don't understand
reversed of F represents the function f
to be applied with its arguments
reversed I see I think this is the sort
of thing that we would document by by
giving their full rotation group
reversal reverse to f of X and Y is f of
Y acts exactly exactly and what will we
do with curry leave it as as just curry
I think so I mean it's obscure but it's
I don't really see that any reason to
decorate it right
in NZ reversed applied or reverse
applied now I I'm saying we have it
reversed I mean I'm saying if you think
reversed well if if it was reverse it
will be reverse applied reverse applied
integrate reverse applied I mean I could
imagine several other things in this
family yeah we discuss it at some point
but applied indeed would it work in this
family does it part of this family I
think so what does it do it makes sure
that the thing is applied in batches yes
so the idea was math of but applied of F
comma list it was applying batches
what about curry applied gives you some
idea what the heck curry otherwise curry
just looks like some kind of Indian food
type thing
although I see the currying of curry
itself doesn't really fit with curry
applied Korea plight of that fits fine
right but you know curried curry and
currying itself is kind of an obscurity
anyway it's not clear that curry curry
itself is going to be the most useful
thing
no but but it was the origin of all all
this discussion um an advantage of these
is that more than a change of syntax of
a function it will be like creating a
new name sorry what yes I was thinking
that rather than a change of syntax in
curry this would be a change of name if
we decide to go from curry to carry up
light you know look I actually think
curry applied is quite nice because
there's a say if somebody just sees a
raw piece of code that says curry
applied okay they are you know it's kind
of obscure but at least they know it's
something to do with the way the
function is applied I might think it
means that curry was applied to the
function and wonder what curry was well
yes then you'd be off and running I mean
that's fine
what do you mean what curry was as
opposed to some what you're doing
something to F not necessarily that
you're changing how F does things to
other to its arguments I agree
unfortunately English does not have that
distinction
I think reverse applied operator applied
curry applied it's my best best foot
forward on those things
why doesn't apply work
I mean why why I applied versus apply um
makeup like carita no it's curry apply
and operator apply because they mean the
wrong thing because that what this is
doing Jeremy is it's changing the way
that this thing
it's an operator applied version of F
okay
so it does this it's a fairly obscure
concept I mean it's it's useful but it's
a fairly obscure concept
I think apply conveys that idea better
than applied does you reverse applying F
to its arguments better than normal
applying it what are you saying
I get so if we do reverse apply of F of
arguments I think that communicates what
it's doing more clearly but we also have
applied doing something very different
because this is yeah this is not engine
goes to F of YX that sounds like you're
applying F to its arguments in reverse
order
but like Jose said apply means something
slightly different we do have now things
like image apply video apply excetera
yeah yeah we can't use apply look the
question is whether the thing you are
creating is a noun in which case it is
the operator applied version of F which
is what I think we should do because
these things will be on their own it's
you know it'll just be hanging out as
you know reversed of order or something
and you'll just see that thing as a
thing on its own right so you'll see
things like f arrow reversed of order so
f are a reverse applied of order I don't
think that's terrible I think that's
unjust you know that there's you have a
fighting chance of understanding what
that is I think it's better than
reversed of order actually it says
that's a function it's reverse applied
whatever that means
yep an operator applied here means that
so by the way the second argument to
operator applied can you say operator
applied of F comma Y of X no the second
argument is the same as curry the
permutation and number of arguments this
sort of thing is that a good idea or
should we do this instead well we do
need to have the information of how many
arguments it's waiting for
why do we think it's more than one well
because we have all this operator forms
that take to like my pad etc all of my
pad
yes we have an operator form of my dad
in which you can say F comma n the
position and then the list you can say
it if one two three there yeah okay so
what's your point about that the the
what you want to do is you want to be
able to say operator applied of Matt
Matt and now that's now we would say
this would be 1 3 2 1 3 2 like this no
no no once the permutation wants you to
okay yes and now you can pass these
three arguments f comma 4 comma list
well I can do it like that right yep but
I can't put this operator plight of a
third argument here no what do you mean
oh I see what the wrong because I could
imagine doing something where I do this
where I say operator replied map at
three comma and then the then even ver
args the other arguments well our
original idea was to have all the
arguments in additional brackets outside
you could also say bracket F bracket for
bucket lists sure no I mean in the
operator replied form it is Auto
currying so to speak it doesn't care
whether it's whether it's got sub values
or whether it's direct all right listen
I think we should go ahead and implement
operator applied reverse applied curry
applied okay okay I think that's the
least crazy after many many hours of
discussion of this that's the least
crazy solution okay okay
we've got Jeremy and Heidi here we are
talking about date objects so Jeremy
this is the complete where was it this
is the complete inventory of possible
modifiers okay
and my concern on one of these here was
that it's awfully your thing here so
these look very small compared to these
there's a very small font isn't it
compared to this one it's reduced yeah
and we could tweak that but but just to
give the overall weight make the weight
a little less and you could maybe tweak
a button and make it bolder but it's at
some point I think you do want the font
size a little smaller doesn't have to go
that small okay why do you think we
wanted smaller just I guess I thought
the amazing for this list case we're
just seemed overwhelming to see that
much going on at once but I think if
there's less in them if it doesn't have
you know 10 14 55 GMT whatever yeah we
greet is this code that actually runs
yeah yeah this works so those buttons
work at the top you could flip through
those and then there's code in the
styles that you can actually put in your
very cool Jeremy very cool okay so if I
run that how do i how do I run this
thing there I've just run it it's a
style sheet so anything works in that
notebook yeah so high-tech
you
you
perhaps it's the time song which should
be smaller but yes that is absolutely
true the time zone yeah I wanted to do
that but didn't couldn't get at it in
the template and so I couldn't do it
easily but yeah I don't be a little
smaller yes I think that going this
small is unnecessary and I think that if
we can bump up that working it's working
okay
so if you open up the styles there's a
chunk of code that you can just tweak
the font size and we could look at it
is this gold here is this its Demi bold
but it's not much heavier weight than
what we have now and definitely felt
matching our your the ambient font size
was too much in this case
Ali and our live stream is complaining
about the non readability of things like
reverse applied the fact is things like
that I would like to provide the
cautionary tale okay
/ / super useful even though the first
time you see it it's kind of obscure the
point of these things it's like um at
Star which I'm just starting to really
use seriously myself um
and you know these things once once you
get used to them are super useful they
are quite obscure the first and I'm
afraid that one when you see it you kind
of know it's some kind of function to
composition thing the goal with things
like root you know operator applied
is there are cases in which it's just a
really convenient way to think about it
and the goal is if people see that a
piece of code they're not totally
confused if they really want to know
what it is they mouse over it and they
look at what it does but I feel like
that is a it's a self explaining thing
that it is something to do with the way
that the function applies itself to
arguments and I'm I'm actually fairly
fairly happy with it might be wrong but
I think I'm fairly happy with it
um okay anyway back to Jeremy's was this
Weymouth there's the show yes this is
yours yep um
so what are you proposing here yeah open
styles there's just a small chunk of
code there
the colors weird but if you change that
second argument 12 to 13 it'll be a
little larger font
why did it go it picked up your read
finally yeah it's the colors weird what
should I do here I should say well it'd
be hard to plot that value I mean I
think you could just tweak it for now
they on this way
you
you
you
now that's still bold
yeah and there's a setting up there you
could just set it to two plain I think
instead of Demi bold so plain without
quotes instead of Demi bold up there and
that'll work
I'm not horrified by the Deming Bowl by
the way so let's just yeah it depends on
font size I I think it works as long as
the font size aren't too big
yeah
you
I don't know I mean this is so this is
the 13 point type that right yeah I just
that's better okay
you
well maybe this with the dark-blue in
the smaller time zone
I think Dimmie bolts gonna be
overwhelming here yeah okay I think this
is good then I'm good with that I mean
you know in terms of in terms of of
color I think the sort of slightly off
black is in some direction is okay
mm-hmm and I think we're planning to
drop where it says day we're planning to
not have it's a day okay so we're gonna
drop day month and instant so to speak
right boost their self evident that
makes s yep
I think this looks good which one is
instant it's the last one the last one
here okay
that means the span of the whole second
14 past the minute whereas this is the
actual instant in time we could segue to
our other project and discuss what that
might mean but that's a different is
here okay
those hyphens do we believe in them
being the same font and weight as the
other stuff or do we think they should
be different and do we believe that this
is the right sizing
down a point for this maybe yeah since
we've gone up on the rest I could see
that coming down too and I think the -
shouldn't be that dark it could be gray
again fine okay okay looks good let's go
um Steve on our live stream is
complaining the at operator is fully
documented I agree with that
Oh sigh I mean it's so hard to document
a thing which is which is you know like
just generic it's like it isn't it
doesn't I guess that these days we could
document that the add operator is short
for construct
except I'm not even sure that it is I
mean if we held the thing that probably
wouldn't be accepted it's all the
flavors of that though that are get
weird right you combine it with other
characters and they do different thing
that's that's the weird part for me yeah
I mean pretty quick
it does get exotic quickly I mean but
but you know I use slash I use at-at-at
I use at-at I mean but again they're
required tastes like this one
you know we introduced this a few years
ago and I'm already just starting now to
really use it in a serious way and it's
very useful when I want to actually use
it
um but evaluation is important here
because if @ @x evaluates both F and X
but F at X there's not X is directly
affects das right it's a bit of a can of
worms and our syntax table from the
original book certainly handled this but
I'm not sure that we have a great place
in existing documentation for these
things it should be past Devon if you
could make that comment the
documentation people again I'm not sure
that we have a great solution though
sure um
okay I think we finished just in time
here so we go through a whole agenda
didn't we look at that there is a final
topic there but let's leave it for now
today it is a long thing oh no that's a
huge huge huge yes that's a huge topics
it's an interesting topic but there for
nothing right okay thank you very much
thank you to folks on the livestream a
lot of great very useful comments and
see y'all ah another day talk to you
soon